have you or anyone in your family ever
been a patient on a TLC reality Medicine
Show
[Applause]
what's the story what was the show
oh God
that's insane that there's a show called
my feet are killing me
my goddamn back went out again
so we'll take a look at this on
television
just go to a normal doctor you [ __ ]
lunatics tune in tonight uh does this
look infected
my son the goiter God damn who what who
who was the person that you knew that
was on the show
Jesus Christ
I don't know if I'm hearing it is that
like an acting gig or something yeah did
they audition for that
how [ __ ] up are your feet let me see
them just coming in the audition like
[Music]
what's the disease
dude who wants to be on TV for a foot
fungus
do they actually have it or are they
pretending that they had it
who would pretend they have a foot
fungus I thought it was an acting job I
don't know it's just my big break
who books that you know
what the [ __ ] man you said it was your
mother-in-law does your wife have this
same affliction
good it's not biological that's what the
that's what the TV doctor told us
you know the guy they pulled off the
street and put a lab coat on
to stare at these Hillbillies toes
so your mother-in-law is your wife's
stepmother
wait
yeah okay
oh you're you're going it's not genetic
so you're good
oh wow that's something else she sounds
like a keeper I'll tell you that
also why would you ask that what date do
you ask that on do you have any weird
[ __ ] toe fungus going on in your
family
all right clap it off for Timmy yeah
[ __ ] two for two
[Applause]
this one's just funny this is from Dom d
have you ever been so blitzed at the
bowling alley alley you left with the
shoes that you rented on your feet
this motherfucker's out there slipping
but he just got the car washed holy [ __ ]
God damn it officer I haven't been
drinking it's the shoes
put so much goddamn lacquer on these
things where are you Dom
well he stood up sit down
it's not an award you bozo he's like I'm
right here you're waving like a Kennedy
man that's fantastic did you do that
oh you're oh you're a boy did you
probably got some weird foot fungus I
would go on TV and get that checked out
probably had no socks on either huh
kid goes out fresh do you like do you
like wear them until you're like [ __ ] I
got a wedding let me [ __ ] throw on
the bowling shoes the new brunswicks
real quick you got the glove on and
everything
have you ever worn them again
did you wait you didn't go back and get
your shoes
[ __ ] the [ __ ] man
this guy goes I know exactly where he
did that
like you rented in the goddamn shoes
he's like Jesus is that a nine and a
half I know who it is
I left them in Canada the nine and a
half band that we've been talking about
him
now did they hit you up looking for the
shoes back you have to leave your
license or anything also so you left
your shoes there or yeah
never paying for bowling shoes again
everything is coming up dirt ball that's
what I'm talking about
Jesus ah you're rolling in no need to
wait in line gang I'll see you over at
the lanes
he's like he's he's also the friend
that's pushing everybody to go bowling
every night
it's like what do you guys want to hit a
move let's go bowling maybe how about
that I got the shoes in the car
oh man that's [ __ ] beautiful bro give
him a round of applause man holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]